[Music]
let's rob a do what
now they cannot get
away once upon a time I was just a wee
boy worked at post office don't asked
you for 6 months to chop that freaking
yeti off your head get
gone Dan girl of my dreams marmalade you
going to show me right or
what from then on we was
[Music]
Inseparable my mom they raised the price
of her medicine overnight I say when the
system fails you create your own damn
system half a million dollar WR kapoo we
got to take this
serious b b oh God Dam dear sweet Lord
we are
scared it's time we start kicking back
get him the
CL baby I was just
playing I ain't no
criminal I've been chasing her for 2
years hey you see Mama's peels she's
just as much my mama now too
stop I can't tell if you're being
[Music]
[Applause]
honest it's me and you against the whole
wide world
[Music]